ils sont 1200 ilhwa comme on les a
appelés ici faute de mieux
lorsque l'installation de la base
américaine sur l'île de diego garcia les
a chassés de leur pays
début des années 80 les médias
commencent à s'intéresser au sort des
habitants de diego garcia l'île
principale de l'archipel des chagos dans
l'océan indien un peuple exilés de force
vers l'île maurice
dès 1966 par les anglais pour la
construction d'une base militaire
commune avec les états unis un con tu
montres ou bien tu ris parce qu'il est
quand l'une vignes en 67 nous fûmes
deviner en mourut ce même noyé maurice
pour vraiment fine réduit la diagonale
travail dès leur arrivée à l'île maurice
des chagossiens en particulier des
femmes se mobilisent dans les rues de
port louis la capitale
ils dénoncent leurs conditions de vie
réclame des compensations financières
aux gouvernements britannique et surtout
le droit de récupérer leur île
quand on les a mis sur un bateau pour
maurice on avait promis aux îles wade
maison ils n'ont trouvé que des
bidonvilles
quinze ans après la plupart une lutte
encore début des années 90 malgré les
indemnités financières accordées par les
anglais la mobilisation des chagossiens
ne faiblit pas il ne lui encouragé par
le gouvernement mauricien de l'époque
qui revendique sa souveraineté sur les
chagos
il y a quelques semaines de ça la grande
bretagne nous a informé qu'elle étendait
sa zone économique de 200 milles marins
tout autour de l'archipel des chagos et
évidemment que l'île maurice a protesté
à cette occasion les recours en justice
à l'encontre des gouvernements
britannique et américain se multiplient
de longues procédures souvent vaines
jusqu'en 2006
la justice britannique accorder un droit
de retour à quelques chagossiens c'est
une victoire acquise après quarante ans
de lutte je crois qu'ils suivent bien
mille des coûts nous une joie finalement
anéanti en octobre 2008 la chambre des
lords à londres rejeté la demande de
retour des habitants expulsés des chagos
une décision qui vaut encore aujourd'hui
mais depuis mai 2010 neuf un nouvel
espoir se dessine pour les chagossiens
une résolution adoptée par l'assemblée
générale de l'onu exhorte le royaume uni
de restituer sous six mois les chagos à
l'île maurice et de favoriser le retour
des habitants dans leur pays natal
[Musique]